Beyonce gets hit with a minor setback in
her attempt to trademark blue ivy here's
what's going down
Jonathan Schwartz the former executive
vice president of the singer's company
vgk trademark holdings filed an
application in February to trademark
beyoncé and jay-z's five-year-old
daughters named to launch a series of
products but in May veronica Morales the
owner of an LA event planning company
named Blue Ivy challenged the request in
documents obtained by multiple sources
Morales claims the famous couple has no
intention of selling anything and are
just trademarking the name so quote
nobody else could Morales filed a motion
asking the court to have Schwartz who is
facing jail time for an unrelated case
testified arguing that his testimony
could help determine whether Beyonce had
honest intentions or not earlier this
month the 35 year old superstar fired
back asking that the motion be thrown
out since Schwartz no longer works for
her but in a new court ruling a judge
granted Morales motion